listen to Rucker enough to laugh at a
couple of things that you talked to him
about I've known Michael since we did
Tombstone and so anyway he's like well
you know sometimes I just act like I'm
angry and you're like oh so you're not
really you're just at yeah just act like
I'm angry because you know I want
something done or whatever and I just
laugh because I've seen Michael
totally loses
uh you have to ask him about George
cosmatos and when he was doing
um uh when he was in George cosmotto's
face was that just for effect I'm just
wondering if that was for a fact or if
he was really anxious was he were you
like holy he can hit him nah you
never know with Michael you never know